- [Kim] Hi, this is Kim from Khan Academy.
Today we're learning more
about Roe versus Wade,
the 1973 Supreme Court case
that ruled that the
right of privacy extends
to a woman's decision to have an abortion.
To learn more about Roe versus Wade,
I spoke to two experts on the case.
Clarke Forsythe is senior counsel
for Americans United for Life
and the author of Abuse of Discretion:
The Inside Story of Roe Versus Wade.
Melissa Murray is the Alexander
F. And May T. Morrison
Professor of law at Berkeley Law School
where she also serves
as the faculty director
for the Center on Reproductive
Rights and Justice.
Mr. Forsythe, could you set
the stage for us a little bit?
What was going on at this time period?
- [Clarke] Well, there
were efforts in the 1960s
to repeal abortion laws in the states,
and when abortion
activists were dissatisfied
with those efforts, they
decided to go into the courts.
And around 1969, they took
some cases into the courts,
and ultimately there were 20 or more cases
challenging state laws in the courts
between 1969 and 1973.
And Roe versus Wade was a case from Texas.
- [Melissa] Roe was
litigated in the early 1970s.
It was a period of enormous
change in the United States.
We were beginning to see the beginnings
of the Women's Rights Movements,
the beginnings of the Gay Rights Movement,
and, of course, the Civil
Rights Movement of the 1960s
was moving in a lot of
different directions.
At the time, the question of abortion
was very much on the minds of lots
of different state legislatures
because there had been moves to liberalize
much of the criminal law
that dealt with matters
of sex and sexuality, including abortion.
At the time, four
states, New York, Alaska,
Hawaii and I believe Washington
had actually taken steps
to repeal their laws
criminalizing abortion,
and about 13 other
states had taken efforts
to liberalize their laws
criminalizing abortions,
but in a number of other
states, at least 20 or more,
there remained on the books laws
that absolutely criminalized abortion
except in situations where
it would be necessary
to preserve the woman's health or life
or in cases of rape,
incest or fetal anomaly.
- [Clarke] Abortion rights attorneys
sought plaintiffs who could
challenge the Texas law
and the Georgia law.
There were two attorneys from Texas
who found Norma McCorvey who
gave the pseudonym of Jane Roe
for purposes of protecting her privacy,
and she became the nominal plaintiff.
- [Melissa] And so Norma
McCorvey brought this case.
She was a 22 year-old woman
living in Dallas County, Texas
who found herself pregnant
for the third time.
She was unmarried.
Her first child has been born a daughter,
and she'd ultimately signed over custody
of her daughter to her mother to raise
because she was having a
bit of an itinerant life,
wasn't able to take care of her child.
The second child that she
bore she gave up for adoption.
And so when she found herself
pregnant for a third time,
she wasn't willing to do
either of these things again
and wanted to safely and
legally terminate her pregnancy,
but this was impossible
under the Texas law.
Texas had since the 19th century
absolutely criminalized abortion
except in cases where it was necessary
for the health and safety of the mother.
And so she then was
faced with the question
of what was she going to do?
And the only thing she
could think to do then
was to actually challenge the law.
So she was put in contact
with Sarah Weddington
and Linda Coffee, two young
women who had recently graduated
from law school.
Sarah Weddington was only 26 years old
at the time that she helped
Norma McCorvey bring this case.
But they decided to sue the state of Texas
to challenge the constitutionality
of Texas's criminal abortion ban.
- [Clarke] But as the history shows,
there was no trial, there was no evidence,
there were no expert witnesses.
Jane Roe never testified.
As you know, she never got an abortion.
She gave birth and placed
her child for adoption.
- [Kim] Okay, so Roe was Norma McCorvey.
Who was Wade?
- [Clarke] Henry Wade
was the district attorney
for Dallas, Texas where the case was filed
in federal district court.
- [Kim] So this case, I
assume kind of winds it way
through the courts,
and how did the Supreme Court rule?
- [Clarke] The justices declared the Texas
and Georgia laws unconstitutional
and then rewrote a national law,
a national abortion law in which they said
that the states could not
regulate or limit abortion
in the first trimester.
They could regulate more
in the second trimester,
the second three months of pregnancy
to protect maternal health,
and they could regulate
in the last three months
of pregnancy, the last trimester
to protect maternal health or fetal life.
The attorneys for the plaintiffs claimed
that abortion fell within
the right to privacy
even though privacy is not in
the text of the Constitution.
They said it was derived or based
in the language of the 14th
Amendment of the Constitution
even though the 14th
Amendment doesn't say anything
about abortion or the unborn child.
It just uses the term liberty.
And ultimately the Court said
that the right to abortion
was part of the right to privacy
based on the 14th Amendment.
- [Kim] That's very interesting.
So I've learned through
many of these interviews
that this right to privacy is something
that is never actually explicitly stated
throughout the Bill of Rights,
but there's a penumbra of privacy
that you see in a few ways.
What was the court's reasoning
that it was abortion
that could fall under
this zone of privacy?
- [Clarke] If you read the Roe opinion,
on page 152 of the Roe opinion,
Justice Blackmon starts
out by saying that,
he sites a string of
cases since about 1910,
a string of Supreme Court cases
and says that these lead
to the right of privacy,
and we think abortion or
that the right of privacy
is broad enough to encompass abortion.
But then four pages later on page 156,
Blackmon turns around and says,
but abortion, because it
involves the taking of a life,
is inherently different
from all those other cases
that make up the right of privacy.
- [Melissa] So the right of
privacy doesn't actually come
from Roe versus Wade.
It comes from a case decided
about eight years earlier
in 1965 called Griswold
versus Connecticut.
In Griswold, at issue was
a Connecticut state statute
that made it a crime to use contraception
or even to counsel patients
about contraceptions.
Planned Parenthood League of Connecticut
opened up a birth control clinic
in New Haven, Connecticut.
They were promptly arrested,
and the clinic was closed,
and then they were able
to bring this case.
And they argued that the right to be able
to use contraception was
the right of the individual,
the right of the doctor to advise patients
about contraception was
also an individual right.
And the Court in an opinion authored
by William O. Douglas agrees with them,
and the Court articulates
for the first time
this right of privacy,
and this is a right that the
majority in Griswold says
has actually been percolating
in the Court's decisions
for a some time.
- [Kim] Did any of the justices
dissent in the Roe decision,
and if so, why?
- [Clarke] Well, there were two dissents
by Justice White and by Justice Rehnquist,
and Justice White said that
the Court was engaging
in raw judicial power
and that the justices
did not have the right
or the authority to strike
down the abortion laws
of the states and could not rely upon
a doctrine called substantive due process.
Justice Rehnquist said
that there us clear,
historical evidence that many
states passed abortion limits
and prohibitions precisely at the time
of the framing of the 14th
Amendment in the 1860s
leading up to 1868 and that
the evidentiary history,
this history of state limits
and prohibitions on abortion
contradicted any proposition
that the 14th Amendment
was intended to include
a right to abortion,
and that was kind of the
heart of his dissent.
- [Kim] So Roe was not the last word
on abortion in the United States.
There have been several later cases
that were important to this, as well,
like Planned Parenthood versus Casey
or Whole Woman's Health
versus Hellerstedt.
Can you talk a little
bit about how those cases
have altered the scope
of the right to abortion?
- [Melissa] As soon as
Roe is decided in 1973,
there is an effort to sort of roll it back
and hem it in a little bit.
Frank Church, who's a senator from Idaho,
announces the Church Amendment,
which basically says that physicians
don't have to perform abortions
if doing so would conflict
with their conscience
or conscience beliefs.
So again, that's one opportunity
to sort of limit the reach of this right
by limiting the number of providers
who are available to offer abortions.
- [Clarke] In fact, the
Court has kind of cut back
on Roe versus Wade in
four cases over the years.
Harris versus McCrae,
involving abortion funding,
Planned Parenthood versus
Casey, and in other cases,
they've given more
deference to the states,
allowed the states to
pass more and more limits
at least around the margins
even though they've continued holding
to the basic right that Roe created
that there is a right to abortion
for virtually any reason
at any time of pregnancy.
That's still the scope of the right,
but they've allowed marginal regulations
like limits on public funding,
parental notice and consent,
informed consent laws.
But then the Court flip flopped
in 2016, in June if 2016
in Whole Woman's Health
versus Hellerstedt.
- [Melissa] The case makes its way
to the Supreme Court, and in an opinion
that authored by Justice Stephen Breyer,
and it's only an eight person court
because Justice Scalia passes
away in February of 2016,
so just eight people on the Court.
In this decision that's
a five to three decision,
Justice Stephen Breyer notes
that the provisions that were challenged
do not offer the medical
benefits that they claim to offer
sufficient to justify
the burdens on access
that each of those provisions imposes.
- [Kim] What do you see as
the future of Roe versus Wade?
- [Clarke] Well, the Court has failed
as a national abortion control board.
It cannot monitor abortion.
It can't intervene.
It can't regulate or legislate itself.
It can't act as public
health administrators.
It can't investigate.
And I believe it's absolutely certain
that the Court, sooner or later,
will have to overturn the
Roe versus Wade decision
because of this failure and
return the issue to the states.
- [Melissa] When we are
talking about repealing
or reforming these laws
in the 1960s and 1970s,
it's also around a social movement
where one of the critical questions
is what will be the role
of women going forth
in a modern society?
When the questions of contraception
come before the Court,
one of the questions is
whether women will be allowed
to choose when and how to have children,
whether they can space
the timing of births
to accommodate careers.
It's the same issue that
comes up in abortion.
Like this is allowing women freedom
to be able to go into the workforce,
to determine when and how
they will become mothers,
and so it's not surprising
that the same questions
that arose in the 19th century
about the place of women,
about what happens in a society
that's undergoing change,
whether it's immigration
or changes in the
demography of the country,
are also coming up in the 1960s and 1970s
at a time of incredible social change,
and I think abortion and
these rights involving
a woman's role really do come to the fore
and are incredibly controversial.
- [Kim] So we've learned that the decision
to legalize abortion in Roe versus Wade
was based on the right of privacy,
which the Court has inferred
from the due process clause
of the 14th Amendment.
Since the Roe decision,
a number of other cases
have set limits on abortion
and abortion clinics.
Clarke Forsythe argues
that the Supreme Court
has failed in regulating abortion
and that the issue should
be returned to the states.
Melissa Murray, by contrast,
suggests that the
decision in Roe is crucial
to giving women the freedom
to join the workforce
and make decisions about
when to have children.
To learn more about this case,
visit the National Constitution Center's
Interactive Constitution
and Khan Academy's resources
on US government and politics.